hey everybody i'm dave rubin it's the
reuben report direct message it is
february and in the year 2022 we are
live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv
share subscribe notification bell you
know the drill and today we are doing a
reuben report locals community uh q a if
you want to still get your questions in
over the course of the next half hour 45
minutes you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com or download the
locals app and search the reuben report
community and my team is in the live
chat right now and although they've
given me questions for today's show
questions can be added on the fly okay
imagine someone on cnn actually doing
something unscripted on the fly what an
abject disaster that would be but we're
willing to play with it here uh we like
to do one story up top before we do
these q and a's and i saw this tweet by
jordan peterson you know jordan peterson
i saw this tweet by him
last night i thought it was quite
interesting i wasn't a conservative
until liberals cow towed
to radicals
i thought man i know a little something
about that so i want to unpack that
tweet for just a bit talk about the
labels to liberal and conservative mean
anything anymore as is there anything
left on the left all the sort of stuff
that you know i've sort of talked about
over the last couple years and we put a
little compilation together of some
prageru videos that i did over the years
sort of showing you my own evolution and
i think if you're watching this perhaps
it matches some of your evolution as
well before we get to that and all the q
a i want to talk to you guys about cozy
earth you know one of the best things
about being filmed from the waist up is
that i can look like business up top
while being super comfy down below for
those of you who have been working from
home and participating in multiple zoom
meetings over the past year you know
what i mean that's why no gift will be
more appreciated this valentine's day
than cozy earth sheets pajamas or
loungewear i really dig their sweats i
have done the show at least in one
occasion wearing this their sweats uh
they're so soft and lightweight and
that's because they are made from
super soft viscous from highly
sustainable bamboo cozy earth's bedding
and loungewear are also temperature
regulating so you'll sleep comfortably
year round it's no wonder that cozy
earth has become the bedding of choice
for interior designers and celebrities
cozy earth is so confident you'll love
their products you can try anything
risk-free with their hundred night trial
if you don't love it return it within a
hundred days for free so this
valentine's give the gift that will be
appreciated every single night cozy
earth bedding and loungewear and now my
audience will save 35 on cozy earth
betting and loungewear just go to cosy
earth.com enter my promo code dave and
save 35 hurry that's 35 off at
cozyearth.com
promo code dave cosy earth.com and now
back to me this stuff is seriously super
soft i highly recommend it okay let's
throw that tweet up again for just a
second jordan peterson tweeted this out
last night i wasn't a conservative until
liberals cow towed to radicals so i
wanted to unpack this for just a moment
because i know a little something about
being frustrated with liberals right i
am sort of the why i left the left guy
actually i did a video for prageru a
couple years ago called why i left the
left it was in 2017
and it has been seen 29
million times that's a lot of clicks a
lot of people have seen it it's probably
the thing that really put me on the map
more than anything else as some of you
who read my book may know i actually had
never said that i had left the left
before that nor even in that video in
the video i never actually say i left
the left officially actually that
morning i didn't know the video was
going up that morning and i you know i
wake up i look at my nightstand my phone
is there and i see a notification from
prageru something like dave rubin why i
left the left and i freaked out because
i was like wait a minute i never said
that i'm still part of the left i'm
trying to save the left i'm trying to
show them they're not acting liberally
i'm freaking out and then within a
couple hours i realized that the the
reaction to it was so good and it was
resonating with so many people that it
was
gonna be okay so what we did for you
this morning is we took
three of the prageru videos that i did i
did that first one why i left the left
in 2017.
my next one phoenix if you can just move
forward a little bit so i have some of
the numbers there
with the next one that i did was
oh i've got it right here i want to get
the date right in 2018 i did so you
think you're tolerant uh and then in
2020 i did the bravery deficit which
coincided with
the debut of don't burn this book and
each one i think is a step
in my own political evolution that i
think we can directly relate to what
jordan was tweeting out right there so
we put together uh three little bytes
from each one so this is just small
segments of each one and i think you'll
see what we're doing here take a look
do you believe in free speech do you
believe that people should be judged by
their character not their skin color
do you believe in freedom of religion
if you believe these things you're
probably not a progressive
you might think you're a progressive i
used to think i was i can no longer call
myself a progressive i don't really call
myself a democrat either i'm a classical
liberal a free thinker and as much as i
don't like to admit it defending my
liberal values has suddenly become a
conservative position
so let me ask the question again
who is tolerant well here's the surprise
it's actually those scary right wingers
that the media and the universities
demonize every day
i speak from personal experience maybe
i'm a glutton for punishment here but i
still consider myself a liberal and it's
my duty as a liberal to say what i think
i would rather stand for what i believe
and be hated than bow down and be loved
i can tell you that in the last few
years of my political evolution i've
consistently found conservatives to be
tolerant and open-minded the
understandable temptation is to think
that this politically correct madness
will soon end just die out on its own
well it won't
activists and their mainstream media
allies like the new york times and cnn
propaganda outlets like media matters
and the southern poverty law center and
your local university will make sure of
that big tech with its control of search
algorithms its shadow banning and
deboosting are also in on the game all
of the successes of america and the
western values that gave birth to
america are being eroded as we speak we
can't just blame hollywood the media and
the political establishment any longer
it's time to look in the mirror it's
time to come out of the closet the
political one
you are the solution to the bravery
deficit so what are you waiting for
now first off uh let me address the most
obvious thing i'm aging pretty well you
know there's creams involved a lot of
hairspray uh actually joking aside that
first video that i did there the why i
left the left one from 2017 that was in
the midst of as some of you know i had
developed alopecia areata which is a
autoimmune disease
really only brought on by stress they
don't know why else it would be brought
on and i went for all the blood tests
and all the stuff
and i was losing huge chunks of my hair
and i was on this really awful
experimental medication you can see in
that i have big bags under my eyes i'm
kind of bloated and it was because of
the stress i was getting
from getting online hate from the
so-called tolerant leftists even though
i was only just saying hey let's act
liberally let's defend free speech open
inquiry all that kind of stuff anyway
the reason i put all of this together in
light of the jordan tweet can we throw
the jordan tweet up one more time the
reason i put this all together because
jordan tweeted this out last night i
wasn't a conservative until liberals cow
towed to radicals now i don't want to
speak for jordan peterson obviously so i
you know let's make sure that when when
people understand how we talk about
these words that there's a difference
between a political ideology and a
political party right so people think
that if you say oh i'm a conservative
that automatically means you're a
republican from an american context or
jordan who happens to be canadian it's
like if he says he's a conservative that
means he's part of the conservative
party in canada now the conservative
party in canada is mostly kind of
half-assed not doing it great liberals
they're just like a year or two behind
so i don't think jordan is somehow
saying he is now part of the
conservative party of canada i want to
be clear about that and there's a
difference between saying hey these are
the rough set of ideas that i believe in
say these conservative views or these
classically liberal views whatever it
might be versus i'm a democrat or a
republican that's a political party and
a political party has a platform and on
that platform they do this you know we
we always see this every couple years
they tell you what their platform is and
then the the president or the president
wanna be the guy running for president
is the you know the head of the party in
effect and these are the things we
believe in now of course you don't have
to believe in all those things to be
part of a party but there's a difference
between joining a you know i'm a
card-carrying member of the republican
party and i believe in conservative
principles
all that being said um you know people
always ask me now it's like dave do you
consider yourself a conservative and yes
at this point i do consider myself a
conservative i think that conservatism
for some of the reasons i laid out in
those videos conservatism has become
the wide tent movement that is here to
defend america
now that does not mean that i believe in
every single thing that
is thought of as purely conservative so
the big one for me you guys all know
this i wrote about it in my book is that
i do still consider myself begrudgingly
pro-choice at least for a few weeks we
can have all sorts of debates about that
which by the way i have with
conservatives all the time i've done it
with ben shapiro on this show i've done
it with dennis prager on this show i've
done it with glenn beck on the show and
i've done it with all of them privately
as well um a guy like rudy giuliani
who obviously is a conservative is you
know i always say begrudgingly but he
also believes in a few weak
window on abortion and we can have all
of the discussions about when life
begins and conception and the religious
notions around all of that like we can
do all of that stuff but it's very
obvious to me that within the
conservative movement of 2022 well first
off what are we mainly trying to
conserve it's just america
that thing that we all knew that was
pretty good until the progressives came
and started destroying it over the last
couple years that's the main thing we
want to preserve we want to preserve our
individual rights our liberty
the constitution we want to protect the
documents that free us the bill of
rights all of these things that protect
our ability to live as we see fit i know
that sometimes conservatives get lost in
some of the social issues and i've
sensed that even that is changing let's
not forget that donald trump uh who by
no means is a traditional conservative
certainly not a religious conservative
not only did was he the first first-time
president to ever run pro-gay marriage
so then that seems sort of liberal right
liberal in the sense of equality but
then he appointed clearly conservative
judges to do
uh to make conservative choices when it
came to things like abortion so trump i
mean i was arguing this for a long time
trump was defending both liberalism and
conservatism it's it's a bizarre notion
for this orange you know crazy-haired
guy from new york a builder from new
york that he was doing it
anyway all of this being said um there
is something very rich on the right
right now and that is where i'm going to
spend most of my energy
i know that you know there's this small
tiny set of liberals you know liberals
whatever that means to you at this point
who think that they can stop the
progressives and there's just no
evidence of it it has completely
infected the democratic party it has
destroyed all of the institutions and
while it may be a worthy cause
it may be it really may be it may be a
worthy cause for bill maher to sit there
and say i'm still a liberal but you also
may have to look in the mirror as i said
in that last video and go well maybe
there's a flaw in liberalism itself
that led to the inmates running the
asylum
and i would much rather spend time being
part of a wide tent thing where there
could be you know traditional religious
conservatives more libertarian-minded
people the ex-lefties
you know i know that a lot of you know a
lot of this and the reason i'm doing
this is not only because i thought it
was it's sort of a seminal moment for
jordan peterson to say something like
that because even though jordan
obviously is a conservative to some
degree
this is not by any stretch with his
background and academia and being a
psychologist and all of these things he
in no way is a traditional conservative
so if if he is making
that as a statement now um i think it's
a i think it's a pretty big moment for
those of us that are trying to you know
traverse a path here that makes sense so
obviously this discussion isn't going
anywhere but i thought that would be a
good way to kick off the q a today
starting with tallway he says in light
of the way you ended your broadcast
yesterday it reminded me of an old
saying when it is hardest to hold on to
a dream is when we must all hold on the
hardest of all that being the case do
you see a light at the end of this
tunnel and what do you think
we and the country will look like when
we finally come out of this darkness so
if you didn't see the show yesterday we
ended with a uh two and a half or three
minute compilation video that the daily
wire put together just really going
through the endless lies mostly of cnn
just like how many things they've gotten
wrong and blatantly lied about and the
way they program people to accept more
lies over time so that's what he's
referring to there
what does it look like when we get out
of this thing well
we're getting close to finding out i
think you know yesterday i was really
talking about the narrative shift and
how we're suddenly seeing that it's very
very obvious right now that the
democrats realize that they are going to
get demolished
in the midterms right like you don't
want to be overconfident as someone of
the right or conservative or republican
you don't want to be overconfident
that's the worst thing because then you
depress your people from well i don't
need to vote that day because we're
going to win anyway and then you get the
other people freaking out and then they
vote a lot so you don't want to be
overconfident but all in all polling
it's very obvious and if you're just out
there talking to people it's like
virtually everyone except that very very
small sliver of real sort of woke
radicals
has had it with locism the neo-racism
they've had it with the abuse of
children and the endless masks and the
mandates and everything i mean look
what's going on up in canada when you've
pushed canadians to occupy their own uh
capital you think maybe something's not
right here i know that's not directly
related to america but these things
actually are quite
intertwined these days um so what are we
going to see happen well look as the
narrative shifts the democrats are going
to be opening up states even though you
know new york supposedly opened up today
i'm hearing that at federal buildings in
new york still it's closed so it's a
little unclear if you're in a federal
building in a state that's open
you get all that um but they still want
in many of these places they still want
kids in masks we did the video on stacey
abrams yesterday right she still wants
kids
in masks in uh georgia okay uh we know
that in los angeles even though gavin
newsom saying we're now going to open up
that in l.a county this crazy woman ah i
said california all right throw in
another five uh this crazy woman what
was her name barbara ferrer
[Music]
or something like that like she still
wants kids in masks and she still wants
you wearing masks and supermarkets and
the rest of it
it's your choice if you live in these
places at this point but the narrative
shift and the mainstream media shift
will be that somehow democrats did
everything they could do right we showed
you the video yesterday of hakeem
jeffries uh congressman from new york
talking about how this is all thanks to
joe biden we beat omacron and we can
start opening up and it's just like it's
all nonsense because now all they're
doing is exactly what ron desantis did
from day one that's all they're doing it
life is completely normal here and every
day since i have been here has been
normal and a freaking joy so they are
going to flip the narrative that somehow
i mean you can just watch the media just
know it so that when you see it you know
you can call it out and tell your
friends they're going to somehow trick
you into thinking that it was the
republicans that were spreading covet in
their backwards religious states with
their radical extremists and january 6th
than insurrections and it was the
democrats who did everything guided by
the science and then the science evolved
you get all that so we just need to be
aware that's why these last two days
on the show i've done these more
narrative type shows because we can't
just wake up every day and respond to
the nonsense we have to remember who got
us here and how they did it and i think
if we can do that we can sort of keep
our eye on the ball and figure out how
to win going forward and i do think we
can win and by the way our win is just
that people will live freely right like
that's it
that's it their win is much worse their
win involves gulags dragging people off
whole bunch of nasty [ __ ] brian says
which country would you move to if
america absolutely collapsed
brian you think i'm going to announce
that
why would i announce that right now
so that those looms could follow me to
that place but i do have a place in mind
the weather's pretty good
and i'm going to leave it at that but
i'm not going to tell you sorry well i
don't know maybe the day before i leave
i would just post something for
supporters only in the reuben report
community that would be it but you know
beyond that i can't say anything yannis
says what is the most unexpected thing
you like about florida and what do you
miss about california i miss nothing
about california i mean truly nothing
absolutely nothing
look you know i love dennis prager he's
still there i love his wife sue marissa
who runs prageru and her husband noah i
had a couple other friends did i have
other friends there it's there was a few
people that larry elder loved that larry
elder
yeah i had a couple friends i don't know
what's happened to them they could all
be gone i have no idea what's happened
to all them but yeah there's some people
i miss but i miss nothing about
california absolutely nothing i meant my
had a gorgeous house i had a really
gorgeous house and we had great parties
and uh you know i had this awesome
built-in barbecue situation and we love
to host and you know cook for people and
everything else i don't have a built in
here i just got my big green eggs so i'm
smoking here already i'm smoking the
meats but i don't have a built-in we're
going to work on that but i don't miss
anything i really don't it's been so
wonderful here and that will sort of
parlay with you're asking the most
unexpected thing you know i've been
asked this a couple times and i keep
saying the most unexpected thing is just
how great it is even though i thought it
was going to be great but i'll give you
a little more
granular one on that which is
you know when i lived in la if we had
people come into the house to do things
right like fix lights or patch the walls
or whatever it might be like do
something in the studio or
whatever anyone that was you know
working at the house to do something um
i was always a little well first off we
had people sign ndas because you don't
want somebody coming in whether they
love me or hate me and telling people
where i live or that kind of stuff but i
was always very leery of of people
coming to the house because i didn't you
know
the ideas that i talk about on the show
let's say aren't the most um
there aren't the most
welcomed in a place like los angeles so
we'd have people coming into the house
and i never had a bad experience with
anyone but it was very clear like i
didn't want people going into the studio
if i didn't have to talk to somebody i
wouldn't want to do it so that they
wouldn't recognize me here in florida
everyone that has come to our house from
the the handyman to the guy that was
doing some stuff on the windows to
yesterday we had a girl in a truck who
came and i got a haircut i got my first
haircut in florida she had a little van
she's like a mobile
uh stylist
and everyone
either they've known me and liked me or
it somehow comes up that they're kind of
conservative and they love florida and
they love rhonda it's just that the
people here they get it they just get it
in a deeply in a deep way and i guess
that's not that unexpected but
it's just great it's just great uh
richard says important florida man
question that requires a florida man
answer what is your favorite brand of
orange juice pulp or no pulp now first
off i should address which i've talked
about before that i say florida i know a
lot of people say florida right but i am
originally from new york we say florida
i'm from long island florida i also say
orange juice most people say orange
juice i say orange juice it's just
nothing i could do about it that we're
just going to have to accept it as for
my favorite brand of orange juice the
traditional tropicana no pulp
i've always loved there's that simply is
it simply orange that one has which is
in the the plastic bottle they've moved
in they're pretty good but i'll tell you
i mean fresh squeezed flour at oranges
there's nothing better i would always
prefer to get that at this point i
believe we've got a half gallon jug in
the fridge downstairs right now i don't
even know what brand it is but like some
kind of local florida oh well we got it
at the at the uh street fair here on
sunday the uh farmers market
um but yeah local fresh-squeezed florida
orange juice there's nothing better to
get your daily dose of vitamin c uh
robert says i like the way you have done
the last uh done the show the last two
days what was your reason
for change well you know we got to
florida we set up the new studio this is
again this is the temporary studio at
the moment while we figure out a few
things here although it's working out
quite well actually uh we added phoenix
to the team officially he was our intern
before this and we've all been talking
about ways to expand the show actually
um just yesterday the day before we had
a big sort of vision meeting with where
everybody i asked everybody on the team
to come bring their ideas on how we can
expand and grow and where our weaknesses
are and our strengths and all that and
it really comes from this place of what
i said earlier about not just wanting to
respond all the time
there's a real danger
in the responding all the time thing not
that it sometimes it can be fun and you
know this happened that happened let's
keep talking about these things and
calling out hypocrisy and showing
idiotic videos from msnbc or the mental
institution that is the view or all of
those things like they they need to be
called out
at appropriate times and all that um but
you don't wanna in life i think you
don't wanna just react right you wanna
do something that is putting your best
self forward and that's the way i view
this show so i think the last two days i
mean i really think i don't know that
it's for me to say but i think that the
last two days worth of shows are
probably the two best shows we've ever
done in some ways because
we gave you that sort of narrative this
is what's happened over time and here's
how we can fight it and and don't forget
how we got here kind of taste um so i
would i would liken it maybe a little
bit more to the way tucker does his show
um but i'm doing 95 of it completely off
the top of my head tucker obviously is
reading a script which is completely
fine it's just a different way of doing
things that's not a knock on tucker in
any way i'm just basically telling you
what i think with a with a rough outline
in front of me
um and i try to do it with like a little
more humor and a little more off color
language and that sort of stuff but
we're going to keep doing that and if
you guys have ideas on how we can
explore and expand and go maybe a little
bit more in this direction or that
direction we're really we're really open
and uh you know you always want to keep
reinventing yourself to a degree not
like just abandoning all the things you
used to believe in but like really
finding new ways to do things and i
think you know one of the reasons that
so many uh political pundits
it's not just political pundits like so
many public people sort of go nuts over
the years like if you look at you know
some of the people who i used to
absolutely love a guy like howard stern
who i absolutely loved and he's gone
completely insane it's like every day he
wakes up it's like what's in the news
i'm just going to talk about it and you
just start going crazy you just start
going crazy and uh i actually feel more
sane now
than probably at any other point in my
life so i think that's connected perhaps
to some of those conservative views i
talked about up top uh landon says do
you think we can keep up the momentum to
win seats in november it feels they are
playing the game to ease and then to get
reelected yeah i mean look that's why i
said the thing about overconfidence like
politics is weird the world changes so
fast none of us could have predicted
these last two insane insane years like
are they going to start pushing climate
lockdowns will they tell us in a month
from now if they feel like too many of
us are starting to get back to life and
be happy again that suddenly there's the
new variant you know the unicron variant
if you get the unicorn reference that's
impressive um
like who knows who knows what they will
do so we can't be overconfident
but if it's just left up to people if it
really is just left up to people
like the choice is so
obvious like and it doesn't mean you're
a conservative in that traditional sense
if you were someone you know just again
to bring it back to this sort of like
what's happening to the liberals idea if
you are someone who watches bill maher
every day you've been a liberal your
whole life you're an atheist and a
liberal and an enlightenment person and
you think ted cruz is dangerous
but you're a bill maher type guy so you
hate wokism you're against critical race
theory
um you are for free speech etc etc you
have to vote for republicans you have to
so just get to the end of the road and
vote for republicans and then you might
also try this have a drink with a
republican
have a they're gonna drink scotch and
whiskey that's all they drink and
they're gonna smoke cigars okay i don't
love cigars okay i find them rather
filthy disgusting your clothes stink
after okay uh but if you have a drink
with them you're gonna find out that
they're pretty decent people and you can
get them to drink tequila it takes time
they have to have one or two whiskeys
first and then you can have them get to
kill it they'll usually say it's too
sweet
i don't even remember what the question
was but i think i made a point there you
see the point the point is
we got a chance i'm kidding i know what
the question was
i love it they're bringing me the
question back i remember the question um
the point is like there really is a
chance
to
to really win like get some real
political wins and it's not because then
we will all have to think the same thing
it will be exactly what's in the
republican party platform it will be
that we will vote in people who will
kind of be like oh i'm not the king that
would be pretty much good enough for me
robin says i'd like to hear your
thoughts on mitch mcconnell calling
january 6 an insurrection and his
support for cheney and kinzinger how do
you think this will affect the gop and
conservatives in 2024 well look this is
the battle for conservatives uh outside
of what i just talked about so
conservatives want to show a little more
openness let's say which i think they've
already done like it's just
it's just obvious and done but the
battle for what the future of the
republican party will be of course is
this sort of like liz cheney adam
kinzinger who he just he just stepped
down right or he's not running for
reelection if i'm not mistaken liz
cheney it looks like she's gonna get
tossed in
in montana i think harriet hageman who
actually saw
at a fundraiser last week i think we
have her on the show next week if i'm
not mistaken i was in two weeks i was
very very impressed by her she's she's a
republican running against cheney sorry
wyoming not uh not montana um
this is the battle for the republicans
that they have to figure out which way
are we gonna go like a guy like mitch
mcconnell i get it he's been around
forever he's the ultimate swamp creature
he's occasionally done some good things
does he really think that january 6 was
an insurrection
look was january 6 messi yes did some
people do things they shouldn't have
done if you broke windows and busted
through the capitol and all of those
things yes if you committed a violent
act of course you did something wrong
but there are so many videos of police
literally welcoming people and people
wandering through respectfully looking
at the pictures on the wall talking to
police officers who were saying them hey
you guys are welcome here um there were
no plans for an insurrection like we're
taking over the government there was one
guy who maybe had a lego set of the
capital it turned out it wasn't even out
of the box yet so he didn't even figure
out how to get up the
stairs and figure out where all the
stuff was like you know you had the guy
from the simpsons with the horns on his
head it's like
it was misguided it was confused all of
those things but you know two years
after watching
leftists destroy so many of our cities
destroy public property private property
attack people on the streets block
bridges blah blah blah it's like the
focus on that is only because some
people decided to go to the seat of
power and have their voice heard some of
them may have been misguided in how they
went about that fine fine
um but mcconnell
he's a swamp creature so he wants to
defend the swamp and i think this is the
battle that republicans are gonna have
to face like we can't we can't really
have these liz cheney's around anymore
like what is liz cheney conserving
conserving what makes her a conservative
you know she's loved by the media now so
she's loved by the new york times now
they love her on msnbc they love her on
cnn do you think liz that maybe that
means that whatever principles you had
at one point are going out the window
because you're loved by the machine that
hates conservatives
think about it liz they think
margot after we win the war on communism
will you and david be opening a
restaurant bed and bath or plan to
escape somewhere else tropical
i suppose this is similar to if we lose
the question earlier if we lose where
you're going this is if we win what will
i do um if we win what will i do look if
we won
like really won if somehow america got
fully on track
like if we really returned to our roots
and everything was good
maybe i wouldn't have to do a daily show
i love doing this but like maybe i
wouldn't have to i i've thought about
you know david's a great chef we've
thought about opening a restaurant at
some point or opening a bar
i thought maybe maybe maybe like later
in life maybe in my 60s or something i
could be a mayor of a small town i would
never want to be on the national
political scene but just like a town
that i lived in that i could you know
hopefully
do some stuff maybe that would be
something like good something like that
um i don't know what we would do if we
win if we win we would just
live our freaking lives and it would be
it would be pretty good it would be
pretty good renee says why do you think
joe rogan turned down your offer does
the offer stay around if he has a change
of heart i'm disappointed in his
decision i think he might come on board
at a later date so if you haven't heard
this joe rogan did a stand-up set two
nights ago uh and during a q a someone
asked him if he was gonna take the
rumble off right he made just like sort
of a very
um offhand comment like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna take it uh spotify has
stayed with me and i'm gonna stay there
for now now first off i just want to say
like rumble made an offer like we
thought it was a great idea to make an
offer um as i said it was completely
legit offer yes the offer still stands
perhaps the offer is just a starting
point because it does sound like spotify
uh is paying him more than 100 million
um but joe has just an interesting
spot
he has an interesting position right now
because on one hand he's allowing the
censorship of his show which he did at
the beginning when he signed the deal
and they took off 40 shows then he took
off some more he's now saying there's a
certain word he's not allowed to say but
other people can say is he going to
continue to interview the controversial
people like robert malone et cetera et
cetera i don't know all of those things
are up in the air he may just be saying
hey i did everything i could do and it's
a hell of a lot more than most people
and i'm okay just having some money and
and maybe slightly censoring myself a
little bit like i don't know and i i
don't know that i don't mean that in
like real judgment of him right like i
was discussing with david over dinner
last night it's like if somebody came to
me right now and was like dave we'd like
to give you a hundred million dollars a
year uh but what you're gonna have to do
is take that one jordan peterson
interview you did you're gonna have to
take that off uh because he talked about
gender pronouns and uh we don't like
that but we'll give you 100 million
dollars it's like
i'd at least have to have a discussion
about it like we by the end of the
conversation we both agreed that i
wouldn't do it but it's easy to say when
it's not right in front of you right
like this is just a raw honest
assessment of things like everyone has
their
everyone has their own considerations i
would say that's look we're doing fine i
don't want to be more famous i don't
even really want more money like
everything's fine i'm good i like doing
what i'm doing we're doing something
good here i really believe that um
but joe has his own considerations so
just to be clear the offer still stands
the offer is legit it's probably just a
starting point and we'll see what
happens i guess that's really the issue
is over time maybe maybe joe will
realize i don't know this to be the case
because it hasn't happened yet but maybe
he'll be like you know boy i'm not
interviewing as many controversial
people because i don't want to deal with
the headache and maybe the conversations
won't be as interesting to him and then
maybe he'll want to bring on another
controversial person or maybe you know
he has alex jones on all the time for
example he's buddies with alex jones
it's like is spotify going to be okay
with alex jones being on going forward
they've they've said what they are as a
company
right
and i would suspect that the same
employees who are angry about having joe
rogan have those conversations will be
angry when he brings back alex jones you
know he took off a couple episodes with
michael malus it's like michael malus is
a great guy he's a buddy of mine michael
malus is not a racist or anything close
to that
but like are you going to have michael
malus back on these are all the things
that he has to think about and i think
the best we could do
is say hey we're here we're in the fight
and uh you know sometimes sometimes you
end up fighting for someone harder than
they want to fight themselves and maybe
he just doesn't want to fight that much
right now and and that actually is okay
in a certain context so we're here and
i'll just keep fighting the best way i
can uh philip says since it did not work
out for you and cali are you now
petitioning for desantis to declare the
reuben as florida's official state
sandwich i like this now of course ruben
r-u-b-i-n is different than the
technical spelling there's a u and an e
and another in there of the uh the
reuben sandwich i do enjoy the reuben
sandwich and uh i guess i can say this
now i am interviewing ron desantis it's
coming up soon it's going to be in
person might be here in the house we're
figuring out maybe it'll be on location
somewhere
i will bring that up to him i would like
the reuben to be the official
sandwich can you can you google does
florida have an official sandwich is
there an official sandwich of florida i
guess it would be like
gator related or
something like that
the cuban sandwich is the official
sandwich of florida
the fried grouper ah okay so apparently
there are two state sandwiches of
florida the cuban sandwich that makes
sense especially for you know miami area
and fried grouper i love grouper
i love grouper i will eat grouper fried
blackened
bronzed
baked
sauteed
love the grouper great fish
joe says who do you have in the super
bowl
cincy or la uh i did not watch one
minute of football this season
it's sort of like all sports at this
point there was about eight years ago i
just forgot to watch baseball one season
like something happened conor is very
pissed at me he loves baseball big
dodgers fan over there i just forgot to
watch a season and then i realized like
i don't know that i could name one
major league baseball player judge
there's a guy judge tom judge bob judge
jim judge what
aaron judge all right he's on the
yankees all right pretty good i got that
one i just didn't watch football this
year i don't mind watching football uh i
actually kind of dig football i never
was like hugely into it but if the
choice is cincinnati bengals versus the
la rams they the rams still got thank
you again i can't look this way for
sports i got to look that way okay
michael's like i have no idea
uh
well i'm not voting i'm not going for la
obviously i hope they get destroyed i
hope cincinnati wins literally 137 to
two
which would be better than zero like if
there's just one safety if the final
score of the game is 137
to two that would i hope i hope la
implodes in the middle i hope there's a
massive earthquake in l.a i hope gavin
knew
trying to be nice okay calm down dave uh
next uh holly says there was bipartisan
support in the virginia senate vote to
stop the masking of children in schools
is this just a glimmer of hope or a more
significant sign of the times it is a
significant sign what am i always
talking about we need these moments
right we need some of these wins the
yunkan
win in virginia was one of these things
and now he is
standing up for some of the things he
campaigned on so they're going to get
masks out of schools
they're going to get critical race
theory out of the schools etc etc so
there's some winds and look these winds
are going to come state by state they're
not going to come from the federal
government as long as brandon is in
charge of this thing or whoever's
pulling brandon's uh
straws of his strings you know what i
mean i was just trying to picture
brandon he's like a straw man sort of um
i don't like that branded guy by the way
no one said let's go brandon in a while
so if you guys has a favor to me could
just start saying it again i feel like
it needs to kind of get out there there
was a story this morning that inflation
is even worse than people thought it's
like let's go brandon man um but yes i
think it will come at the state level
we'll just see more and more and again
what the republicans need to do what
what red states need to do and even the
blue states although they'll never give
them credit just model your stuff after
desantis and we can return to a free
country
tom says i try to use rumble as much as
i can i have noticed that the software
is not as user friendly as youtube are
they working on their software to make
it user friendly i hate using youtube
yes absolutely
i promise you that was partly why we did
the merger with them because we got a
great tech stack at locals and we have
great developers and now we're all
working on projects together we just
hired a whole bunch of people there's a
new rumble app coming out we'll have
some really cool updates on the local
side some new features that i'm really
psyched to use so yes you know being a
startup company even when you you've got
some dough it's like there's a lot of
things that you got to put together to
get it all right and also you know
competing with the the slickness
and the user interface of a youtube
that's been around forever it's it takes
time everything takes time you know it's
funny i'll see people say well dave we
want this feature that features
everything and people think you can just
do it like it just like magically
appears like that but we build a lot of
this stuff from scratch and we've got
great people on board and just be
patient
rubio says how are you doing with your
spanish you will be talking before you
know it
i'd like to think i'm doing all right
donde la biblioteca
um
soy
yo tengo pantalones
blanco
that's pretty good and uh one more one
more um i like all the thumbs up i'm
getting today and uh
uh i did donde already and i did jose um
uh quiero
bebo
i want to drink beer
bob says what are your thoughts on
legalizing marijuana
and mushrooms wrote about this in the
book i believe both should be legalized
i am completely fine leaving it to the
states
this is a position by the way that i
have that is not certainly not thought
of as a fully conservative position i
think you can make strong libertarian
arguments on why you want to
decriminalize a lot of this stuff i
don't want people arrested because they
smoked some pot and went to the movies
you know what i mean like it just
doesn't make sense there's there's no if
you're for
legal
alcohol which causes all sorts of health
problems we all know that and drunk
driving and almo there's a crazy
statistic related to domestic violence
and and involving alcohol and it's
almost like all domestic violence almost
all of it includes some level of alcohol
use very few people are smoking a joint
and robbing a bank you know like it just
doesn't happen um that doesn't mean that
marijuana is great and and could it be
to a degree
a gateway to start doing some other
things it could be but you know
everything's a gateway to some extent um
but this is where you have to blend and
we can have we've we can have a great
conversation about this say as
libertarians and conservatives who want
to make sure people aren't doing drugs
because generally the more drug use you
got you start having a lot of that
societal rot that they're having in san
francisco and elsewhere we know that um
so personally i'm okay
with legalizing marijuana again we can
put it at the state level um you can
have age restrictions on it and
everything else and i think it really a
lot of these things you want to fall
back on the parents you want the parents
to hopefully have given the children
enough of a education to know
what they can do and tolerance and
limits and all those things and as far
as mushrooms specifically on the
psychedelic front yeah i'm okay with
that too
i've done mushrooms i haven't done them
in a long time but like i'm fine with
people taking something that is a
completely natural substance from the
earth i mean if you do some research on
it's actually kind of gross psychedelic
mushrooms like psilocybin it grows
they're mushrooms that grow on cow poop
and then people eat them and then you
have this crazy psychedelic experience
it's like that's pretty weird that could
almost make you believe in god right
there like how much more do you need
than that like it's bizarre like who's
the first guy that did that you know
there's a some cow poop and some
mushrooms
let's see what happens um so yeah this
is where you blend you blend personal
responsibility and liberty and a belief
that we have to keep society uh in some
state where there's some guard rail so
not everybody goes bananas this of
course also is where the liberals have
absolutely failed which is why those
cities are such a mess and what was it
just this morning right before we
started there was going to be this
program how much money did they put
towards crack pipes or something
basically the biden administration was
going to have this thing where they were
going to give crack pipes away i mean
literally give crack pipes away like
crazy crazy stuff then of course enough
people
started making hunter biden jokes and
now they will not be giving crack pipes
away but they are going to give drugs
away in these cities and it's like do
you think this is going to stop anyone
from uh from doing drugs what's that
they were putting 30 the federal
government let me just get it right
the fed the federal government was doing
a 30 million harm reduction program
where they were going to give crack
pipes
to crack addicts
and we're called the extremists right
we're called the nut bags of the crazy
people anyway enough of pushback they're
not going to give out crack pipes but
they'll just let you i don't know you
can walk in and get a needle and shoot
yourself with some heroin which i am not
for legalizing
i've enjoyed today's program i hope you
have as well in closing uh my full
interview with glenn beck all about the
great reset uh is up right now on
youtube on blaze tv and of course on
rumble uh if you want to play along join
us at
reubenreport.locals.com that's how you
can get your questions in for next
week's q a and tomorrow we are doing an
all florida as they say an all florida
round table with some new floridians and
some old floridians we've got my buddy
dave reboy and john cardio and carol
markowitz and uh i'm looking forward to
it all right have a great day everybody
see ya